in this lesson we're going to talk about  quadrilaterals and one of the important  things you want to know for the act is  that  quadrilaterals that just means that it's  a four-sided right and that all the  angles are going to sum to 360 degrees  so this is just a reminder in this  lesson that you know when you have a  quadrilateral you can find the missing  angle because you know that these all  add up to 360. so let's just do this  example here together you can do it on  your own if you want to pause the video  but basically what we have is 110  degrees plus 70 degrees plus 100 degrees  plus angle m okay has to add up to  360 degrees  so here we can see that we've got 210  plus 70 is 280 right plus the measure of  angle m equals 360. subtract 280 from  both sides  and you can see that the measure of  angle m is equal to  80 degrees  and that's it you got it so just a quick  reminder quadrilateral sum to 360. you  want to know that for the act i'll see  in the next lesson